COME TO ORDER IN THE MORNING-
IN RESPONSE TO THE WHOLE BIT
NINETEEN ARMORS SEE AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC THE SENATORS.
SENATE STAFF AND- WE MUST LIMIT
OR NON ESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND
IT HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE WILL BE HOLDING AN
ESSENTIAL HEARING. AND HAS MADE%
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO THE
NORMAL PRACTICES. IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WHILE
CONDUCTING THE HEARING IN A WAY
THAT PROTECTS THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC ON OUR
DEPLOYS. AS WE COMPLY WITH
THOSE ORDERS WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS IN THE
CAPITAL WITH SOME OF THE
MEMBERS PARTICIPATING IN THE
DEBATE. REMOTELY WITH THE USE
OF A VIDEO CONFERENCE SYSTEM.
NOW FOR MEMBERS WHO WILL BE
ATTENDING REMOTELY TODAY PLEASE
MOVE YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS
AND IT WILL GREATLY AID IN THE
ELIMINATION OF ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK AND I US IN EVERY
TIME. YOU HAVE A COMMENT OR
QUESTION USE THE RAISE YOUR
HAND FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM.
EACH TIME YOU ARE KNOWLEDGE TO
SPEAK. A POP UP WINDOW WILL
APPEAR ASKING. IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO ON MUTE. PLEASE SELECT
ON MUTE BEFORE YOU BEGIN
SPEAKING. OUR IT PERSONNEL WILL
PUT YOU BACK ON NEW WHEN YOUR
DONE. WHAT'S RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
AND THE BILL NUMBER WHICH TO
YOU ARE REFERRING TO. TO ALLOW
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT THE SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. AND WILL BE
USED IN THE- YOU USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENTS. THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FEE NUMBER
AND ACCESS TO OLD IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I WOULD ANNOUNCE IT HERE.
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
844-291-6364 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. SIX ONE ZERO FOUR ZERO
NINE NINE. WHEN WE MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT A MODERATOR WILL
IDENTIFY YOU INDIVIDUALLY OPEN
YOUR LINE AND AT THAT TIME YOU
MAY ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID THE ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU
MUST NEW TO DEVICE YOU ARE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY. OVER THE
PHONE. ITIS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS CUSTOMARY. AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTED MAY
BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HIRING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE A MANNER TO THE SAME
MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY. THERE
MAY BE SOME LIKE TRANSPORT
PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE ADJUSTING
TO THE USE OF A NEW ONLINE TOOL
AND TECHNOLOGY PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENCE SO ALL
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. AT THIS
TIME OF THE HEARING MEMBERS.
AND WE HAVE- I WANT TO KNOW SO
WE HAVE THE CONSENT CALENDAR
CONSISTING OF ITEM ONE SB NINE
OH NINE. YES BE OF NINE TWO ONE.
SB. ONE ZERO TWO FOUR SB. ONE
TWO THREE EIGHT. SB. ONE TWO
NINE ONE. SB. ONE THREE FIVE
ONE. SB. ONE FOUR FIVE NINE. S.
C. R. SEVEN SEVEN IT IS C. R.
EIGHTY SIX NOW BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATION OF BILLS WITH THE
STATUS ARE QUORUM. SENATOR
BATES. HAS BEEN REPLACED TODAY
FOR TODAY'S HEARING. AND I
BELIEVE SENATOR GROVE IS GOING
TO BE PLACER WELCOME WHEN
CENTER GROSSES YOU'RE WELCOME
HER AND WILL CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE. SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL
WELL YOUR BILL PRESENT ALLEN.
ALLEN PRESENT DOLLY RIGHT THE
ONLY PRESENT DOT. WHY HERE'S
THE ADDRESS OF CALL JOHNNY.
GALGIANI PRESENT GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ PRESENT GROWTH.
MCGUIRE THE. MELENDEZ BILL IN
ITS PRESENT BROWN HERE WELL
PRESENT ROUGH BROUGHT PRESENT
RUBIO. RUBIO PRESENT WHITE
HOUSE SKI. KELSEY HERE YOU HAVE
A QUORUM IS GERMAN. WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
AND- THANK YOU I- MOTION SIR
WHAT CAL SKI AND SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR PLEASE. MEDIA
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR WHICH
CONSISTS OF FILE ITEMS. ONE TWO
THREE FOUR FIVE SIX. EIGHT NINE
AND TEN. SENATE BILL. YEAH WELL
I ALLEN. HI ELLEN HI DOLLY HI
KELLY I THOUGHT. DODD HI
GALGIANI BILLION I GONZALEZ
WELL AS I GROW. MCGUIRE
MELENDEZ MULLIN DESIGN MORRELL
HI WELL HI ROTH HI ROTH HI
RUBIO. I RUBIO HIGH WHITE
CASKET HI MICHAEL SKI I. FOUR
FIVE SIX THANK YOU- WILL BE THE
ROLE OF COMPRESSION MEMBERS- IN
ITS OWN CALL. MEMBERS THAT
LEAVES US WITH JUST ONE BILL
ITEM SEVEN SB ONE THREE SEVEN
THREE BY CENTER BATES AND
CENTER BASIS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY. AND WELCOME CENTER
BATES YOU MAY PRESENT YOUR BILL.
CENTER BATES. I LOVE IT. HEAR
ME GUYS A LESS RIDICULOUS QUITE
WELL OKAY THANK HERE I. AVAIL
AND MEMBERS- RIGHT THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
SB THIRTEEN SEVENTY THREE THIS
MORNING AND CERTAINLY WILL CALL
AS IMPORTANTLY- FOR ALL THE
DISCUSSIONS WE HAVE HAD ON THIS
ISSUE OVER THE PAST COUPLE OF
YEARS. I HAVE TO BE THIRTEEN
SEVENTY THREE SEEKS TO CODIFY
THE DECISION THAT WAS MADE BY
THE TRANSPORTATION CORRIDOR
AGENCY BOARD ON MARCH TWELFTH
TWENTY TWENTY BY DELETING THE
REALIGNMENT OF STATE ROUTE TWO
FORTY ONE SOUTH OF ALSO PARKWAY
AND ALSO PARKWAY IS AND WEST
ARTERIAL RAINING JUST STEINORTH
UP A LITTLE BIT OF THE CITY OF
SANTA MANY. THEREFORE UP TO
FORTY ONE LARA THROUGH THE CITY
OF SAN CLEMENTE TO CONNECT TO
WIFI. ARGUES FOR ONE REQUIRES
YES OUR TWO FOUR ONE AND
CONNECT TO ENTER FIVE OF THE
CITY SAN SO S. THIRTY SAID
THREE IS NEVER. TO REMOVE FROM
THE BOOKS A HIGHWAY THAT STATE
AND REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
AGENCIES HAVE DECIDED TO
ABANDON DUE TO ITS DEVASTATING
ENVIRONMENTAL ECONOMIC CULTURAL
AND SOCIETAL COST IT WILL
CODIFY THE DECISION TO
REESTABLISH THE TRUST AMONG
STAKEHOLDERS AND CERTAINLY
ELIMINATE THE CONTROVERSIES. IT
ROAD RUNNER FOR SEVERAL YEARS
THIS IS A DISTRICTS BILL THAT
WILL BRING CREDIBILITY BACK TO
THE PROMISES MADE BY ALL OF THE
LOCAL LACK OF THE- LET LOCAL.
LEADERS AND I HAVE WITH ME MARK
OF TRAIL. HE WILL TESTIFY ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO. THANK YOU SURVEYS
WILL NOW MOVE IN TO THE PRIMARY
SUPPORTERS AND WE HAVE A MEMBER
IN THE GALLERY AND- MARK AFRAID
OF YOU CAN CALL THE OFFICE- YOU
MADE A PROCEED ON. WORK WITH
OPERATORS IN THE GALLERY OF THE
SENATE. A GOOD MORNING MEMBERS
OF THE SENATE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE THANK YOU SENATOR
BATES FOR THE RECORD I MARKET
PRATT TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF SAN CLEMENTE AND WE
WANT TO THANK SENATOR BATES FOR
OFFERING. THIS MEASURE AND FOR
ALL OF HER EFFORTS AND THE
EFFORTS OF HER STAFF IN
DEVELOPING THIS BILL. WE ALSO
WANT TO THANK THE SENATE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE FOR
SETTING THIS BILL FOR HEARING
IS THOUGHTFUL ANALYSIS AND FOR
ALLOWING US THE OPPORTUNITY TO
EXPRESS OUR FULL SUPPORT. FOR
THE MEASURE SENATOR BATES
OUTLINED THE NEED FOR THIS
LEGISLATION BUT LET ME ALSO
POINT OUT THAT THERE IS
PRECEDENT FOR THIS KIND OF A
MEASURE. LAST YEAR THE
LEGISLATURE GOVERNOR'S NEWS
SIGNED AB TWENTY NINE THIS BILL
UP TO CENTER THE STATE ROUTE
SEVEN TEN. AT LIKE STATE ROUTE
TO FIFTY ONE PROVIDED THAT
AFTER BOTH OF THE STATE THE
REGION HAVE CONCLUDED THEIR
STUDY. ALTER MADE IT. THAT
THOSE PRIDE WOULDN'T GO FOR. BE
A DID IN ON MARCH TWELVE OF
THIS YEAR ABC TWENTY NINE
SIMPLY OF AMENDED EXISTING LAW
TO CONFORM WITH THE DETERMINE
OUTCOME AS DOES THIS MEASURE.
THE SENATE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE LAST YEAR APPROVED AB
TWENTY NINE ON A VOTE OF TWELVE
TO NOTHING SO THEREFORE THERE
IS PRECEDENT FOR THIS BILL. IS
ALL ABOUT THE QUESTION RAISED
IN THE ANALYSIS AS TO WHAT
IMPACT IF ANY THIS MAY HAVE ON
EXISTING LEGISLATION. THAT
DON'T SEE THAT THIS INTERFERES
THE EXISTING LEGISLATION AND
HERE'S WHY. THE EXISTING
LITIGATION BETWEEN THE CITY OF
SAN CLEMENTE. THE RESERVE
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION OF THE
T. C. A. IS A LAWSUIT. OVER THE
MEANING OF THE CURRENT
PROVISIONS OF STREETS AND
HIGHWAYS CODE SECTION FIVE
FORTY ONE. THIS WILL HAVE NO
EFFECT ON THAT LITIGATION AS IT
AFFECTS OR PURPOSELY
PROSPECTIVE. NOT RETROACTIVE IF
ANY QUESTIONS ON THIS ISSUE I'D
LIKE TO. ASK THE COMMITTEE TO
INVITE SAN CLEMENTE CITY
ATTORNEY SCOTT SMITH WITH BEST
BEST IN KRIEGER IF THERE ARE
ANY QUESTIONS. FINALLY SENATE
BILL THIRTEEN SEVENTY THREE
WILL CODIFY THE MARCH TWELVE
DECISION BY THE TCA. AND
REESTABLISH TRUST OVER LOCAL
AGENTS BETWEEN LOCAL AGE HE'S-
THE RESULT IS A- FIVE. IN THE
END ON MARCH DRIVING THE
MAJORITY OF THE T. C. DIRECTOR
VOTED TO ABANDON THE PROJECT
AND STOP AND START TO FORTY ONE
AT ITS CURRENT LOCATION SB
THIRTEEN SEVENTY THREE AS
AMENDED ON MAY NINETEEN
REFLECTS THAT MARCH FULL
DECISION AND LAYS THE
FOUNDATION SO THAT THE TRUST
WITHIN THE COMMUNITY. MAY BE
RESTORED. FINALLY THE CITY OF
SAN CLEMENTE JOINS WITH THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE IN
THEIR DESIRE TO ENCOURAGE THE
PARTIES TO REESTABLISH TRUST IN
REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION.
PLANNING AND KEEPING THE
THIRTEEN SEVENTY THREE MOVING
FORWARD WILL FACILITATE THAT.
WE THEREFORE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR IDOL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I KNOW WHAT TO
CALL OUT OF THERE ARE ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN THE GALLERY
WHICH SHE TESTIFIED FOR THE
BILL PLEASE COME FOR. AND I SEE
NOT. AT THIS POINT WE HAVE AN
ALTERNATIVE ROOM ROOM TWO ZERO
FOUR ZERO LET'S SEE THAT LIKE
TO CALL ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM
TWO ZERO FOUR ZERO WHICH I'VE
TESTIFIED SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
I LOVE THAT AND I SEE NONE.
THANK YOU AND NOW WILL MOVE TO
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WAITING TO TESTIFY- IN SUPPORT
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE SERVICE.
MODERATOR PLEASE PROMPT ANY
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE. THREE
SEVEN THREE AND LET ME KNOW HOW
MANY PEOPLE THERE ARE. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE
THREE SEVEN THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AGAIN THAT'S ONE ZERO.
IF YOUR SUPPORT OF SB. ONE
THREE SEVEN THREE. ONE MOMENT
MISTER CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU OUR
MODERATOR PLEASE OPENING I FOR
PEOPLE. THANK YOU HOW MANY
PEOPLE. YEAH FIVE PEOPLE
SHOWING UP RIGHT NOW SIR ONE
MOMENT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU MODERATOR
AND PLEASE OPEN THE LINES AND
CALL FOR THE SUPPORTERS. WE
HAVE. LINE NUMBER FIFTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LINE NUMBER FIFTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MAYBE
A LINE THAT MUTE. LINE ONE OF
HELLO MY NAME IS CRAIG WARD I'M
A RESIDENT AND COME AND PLAY
AND I AM IN FULL SUPPORT OF
THIRTEEN SEVENTY THREE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE
NUMBER TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS MICHELLE SCHUMACHER
AND THE CO FOUNDER OF NOT MY
TOLL ROAD OUR GROUP IS OVER
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND. STRONG
FROM CALIFORNIA COUNTY CITY WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIRTEEN
SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR. YEAH. THANK YOU LINE
NUMBER SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING YES MY NAME IS AMANDA
KING SO YOUNG FOR SB THIRTEEN
SEVENTY THREE I'M A FIFTY YEAR
RESIDENT OF ORANGE COUNTY AND A
REGISTERED NURSE I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB THIRTEEN SEVENTY
THREE. I RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MY NUMBER FOURTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS WILLIAM SCOTT
TIME FOR NEWPORT BEACH
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT BILL THIRTEEN SEVENTY
THREE THANK YOU. LINE NUMBER
THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD YEAH I GOT A
LOOK AT IT NOW. MY NUMBER
THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
MAYBE YOU'RE ON YOU. I AM BODY
BARNES BOARD PRESIDENT OF
RANCHING SAN KHAMENEI'S MASTERS
SENSATION OF HOMEOWNERS
REPRESENTING FOURTEEN H. AWAY
AND OVER FIVE THOUSAND
RESIDENTS. ARE IS HE HE H.
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB THIRTEEN
SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU. I MEAN
WE HAVE NO MORE IN Q. WE GIVE
NOTICE NOW THAT. WE'RE GOING TO
CLOSE OWN THE HEARING FROM THE
SUPPORTERS IS THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS MODERATOR.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO ROLE
IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE THREE
SEVEN THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
DIDN'T ZERO. THAT'S ONE ZERO SO
YOU SHOW THEIR SUPPORT. THEY'RE
NOT BOTH IN AT THIS TIME MISTER
CHAIRMAN WE HAVE NO MORE
SUPPORTERS. THANK YOU. LET'S
BEGAN- OF THE PROCESS- TO HEAR
FROM ANY OPPOSITION- LET'S
BEGIN WITH ANY WITNESSES HERE
IN THE GALLEY GALLERY- THE
SENATE ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO SB. ONE THREE
SEVEN THREE. PLEASE COME FOR.
WE HAVE A WITNESS. YOU MAY
PROCEED CHAIR AND MEMBERS GOOD
MORNING NATE SOUL OF ON BEHALF
OF THE TRANSPORTATION QUARTER
AGENCIES TO JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITIES THE SAN JOAQUIN
HILLS AND FOOTHILL EASTERN
AGENCIES WHICH PROVIDE OVER
FIFTY MILES OF TOLL ROADS IN
ORANGE COUNTY- THROUGH THE
REGIONAL ECONOMY INCLUDING AT A
SAN DIEGO RIVERSIDE AND SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTIES. TCS BOARDS
OF DIRECTORS ARE MADE UP OF
CITY COUNCIL MEMBERS FROM
EIGHTEEN CITIES AND ARE ORANGE
COUNTY SERVICE AREA AS WELL AS
THE COUNTY OF ORANGE. TCA TOOK
OPPOSE POSITION ON THE PRIOR
VERSION OF THIS BILL BUT SINCE
IT WAS AMENDED LAST WEEK THEY
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO TAKE A NEW
POSITION UNTIL THEIR NEXT
MEETING ON JUNE ELEVENTH. THE
ISSUE WERE DISCUSSED TODAY HAS
BEEN DEBATED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
FOR MANY YEARS. WHAT TYPE OF
ROAD SHOULD BE CONSTRUCTED IN
SOUTH ORANGE COUNTY. TO REDUCE
TRAFFIC WHILE LIMITING ADVERSE
IMPACTS. ON MARCH TWELFTH
CONSISTENT WITH THE PROCESS
THAT WAS STARTED IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN A PATH FORWARD WAS
IDENTIFIED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
AFTER YEARS OF PUBLIC OUTREACH
AND COLLABORATION BETWEEN LOCAL
RESIDENTS AND CITIES THE ORANGE
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
AND CALTRANS. THE FOOTHILL
EASTERN BOARD COMPLETED ITS
STUDY AND VOTED TO ADOPT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND A SCOPING
SCREENING REPORT THAT ONLY
IDENTIFIED ONE BUILD OUT
ALTERNATIVE FOR FURTHER
EVALUATION. CALLED ALTERNATIVE
TWENTY TWO ONE TOLL. AN
EXTENSION TO THE EXISTING LOS
PATROLLERS PARKWAY. THIS
ALTERNATIVE PROVIDE SUBSTANTIAL
TRAFFIC RELIEF AND SOUTH ORANGE
COUNTY WOULD TERMINATE AT THE
NORTHERN TIP OF THE CITY AND
WOULD NOT GO THROUGH ANY
DEVELOP PORTION OF THE CITY OF
SAN CLEMENTE. THE FOOTHILL
EASTERN BOARD'S DECISION
REFLECTS NOT ONLY THE PUBLIC'S
AND MULTI AGENCY INPUT. BUT IS
SUPPORTED BY THE PRELIMINARY
ENVIRONMENTAL ANALYSIS AND THE
TECHNICAL DATA THAT SHOWS THIS
ALTERNATIVE PROVIDES TRAFFIC
RELIEF THREE TWENTY FIFTY. THE
PHOTO EASTERN BOARD FELT THAT
IT'S ACTION ELIMINATED THE NEED
FOR THE BILL. THE FOR EASTERN
BOARD IS SLATED TO DISCUSS THE
REVISED BILL AT ITS JUNE
ELEVENTH MEETING AND CONSIDER
ANY POLICY IN TECHNICAL
CONCERNS AS WELL AS POTENTIAL
IMPACTS OF THE LITIGATION SAN
CLEMENTE HAS FILED AGAINST YOU
SEE A CALTRANS AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS. WOULD LIKE TO SEE
ALTERNATIVE TWENTY TO MOVE
FORWARD TO THE NEXT STAGE OF
THE PROCESS AND SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO UPDATING YOU WILL
WITH THE POSITION AFTER THE
JUNE ELEVENTH MEETING THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU VERY VERY
MUCH. ARE THERE ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES HERE AND- SENATE
GALLERY. IT'S TIME FOR. I SEE
NO WITNESSES. AT THIS POINT I
LIKE TO US OR THEY'RE WINNING
WITNESSES IN ROOM TWO ZERO FOUR
ZERO WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB ONE THREE.
SEVEN THREE. AND I SEE NOT. AND
THANK YOU WILL NOW MOVES ON TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. VIA
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS MODERATOR
PLEASE PROP INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
ONE THREE SEVEN THREE AND LET
ME KNOW HOW MANY. PEOPLE THERE
ARE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH. TO WILL IN OPPOSITION
OF ONE THREE OF SB ONE THREE
SEVEN THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
DIDN'T ZERO. IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF BE ONE THREE
SEVEN THREE THAT'S ONE THAN
THEIR OWN NOW. ONE MOMENT
MISTER CHAIRMAN ONE PERSON.
ACTUALLY UP TO NOW IN THE JUNE.
FIFTH THANK YOU MODERATOR WOULD
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES AND CALL OPPOSITION
WITNESSES INDIVIDUALLY WE WILL
CONTINUE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ONE NUMBER ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. CORY TALK
AND THEN ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF MISSION BE A HELL THIS IS A
LOCAL ISSUE AND THE CITY OF
MISSION BE A HEALTH AND STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THE- BILL. MY
NUMBER NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS TELL ME DEAL I AM THE MAYOR
PRO TEM OF THE CITY OF RANCHO
SANTA MARGARITA AND A MEMBER OF
THE TRANSPORTATION CORRIDOR
AGENCY BOARD OF DIRECTORS. THE
CITY OF RANCHO SANTA MARGARITA
STRONGLY OPPOSES THIS BILL.
ALSO IT IS FALSE CLAIM THAT
THIS PROPOSED LEGISLATION
CODIFIES PRIOR ACTION TAKEN BY
THE TRANSPORTATION CORRIDOR
AGENCY. THE P. C. EIGHTY HAS
NEVER TAKEN THAT ACTION. IT IS
ALSO FALSE TO SUGGEST THAT THIS
LEGISLATION WOULD STOP
CONTROVERSY. THE EXACT OPPOSITE
IS TRUE THIS LEGISLATION WOULD
BE OPPOSED BY MANY CITIES
INCLUDING THE CITY OF RANCHO
SANTA MARGARITA AS WELL AS
MISSION BE A HELPFUL AND OTHERS.
ALSO THIS IS THE LOCAL ISSUE
THAT IS HIGHLY CONTROVERSIAL IT
IS NOT A STATE ISSUE. AND
SHOULD BE LEFT TO THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO RESOLVE.
ESPECIALLY DURING THIS VERY
DIFFICULT AND CHALLENGING TIME
WITH COLLUDED NINETEEN. THE
STATE LEGISLATURE HAS FAR MORE
IMPORTANT THINGS TO DO THAN TO
GET INVOLVED IN. CONTROVERSIAL
LOCAL ISSUES WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NO MORE IN Q. PLEASE.
AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO MORE IN
Q. OKAY MODERATELY CHECK GO
JUST ONE MORE TIME TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE HEARD ALL THE
OPPOSITION WITNESSES PLEASE.
YES IF YOU ARE IN IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB ONE THREE
SEVEN THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. ONE THEIR OWN NOW.
IN AT THE TIME OF THE TERM AND
WE HAVE NO MORE IN Q. MOVE THE
BILL. NOW WE HAVE A MOTION ON
THE BILL AND- THANK YOU TO ALL
OUR THE SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
WITNESSES WILL BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO OUR MEMBERS.
COMMENTS REMEMBERS SEVERAL I
TELL CITY AND CENTER RUBIO.
MISTER CHAIR IT IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT THE HEAT TESTIMONY HAS
CREATED SOME UNCERTAINTY OF
REGARDING THE FINALITY THAT'S
BEEN TAKEN BY THE EASTERN
TRANSPORTATION QUARTER AGENCY.
WHAT I'M CONCERNED WITH IS
NORMALLY THE LEGISLATURE LOADS
GETTING INTO THE MIDDLE OF A
LAWSUIT AND I KNOW WE HEARD
TESTIMONY FROM STE CITY OF SAN
CLEMENTE IN THE INDICATION WAS.
THE CURRENT. AND THE- WHAT
AFFECTED EFFECT THIS DECISION
EN YOU DON'T EVEN HAVE LAWYER
LAW ME NO THAT YOU CAN YOUR
CAUSES OF ACTION IN THIS
DECISION WAS MADE ON MARCH THE
TWELFTH WHICH IS LIKE HOURS
BEFORE THE CODE LAW DOWN IN
REALLY NO HAS BEEN GOING ON
CITIES IN AN ORANGE COUNTY AS
THE- THANK. BONDS IT WOULD SEEM.
A PREMATURE THIS TIME. TO THE
I'M GOING TO OF STAYING AMMA
VOTING NO I'M GOOD ABSTAINED
BUT I JUST WANTED TO GIVE YOU
AND THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THE BENEFIT OF MY
THOUGHTS ON ON THE TIMING OF
THIS BECAUSE THIS IS. A HEARING
IT COULD GO ON I DON'T KNOW IF
THAT THAT AGENCY THE CORRIDOR
AGENCIES GOING TO FEEL AS AS
STATED MARCH THE TWELFTH. SO
WITH THAT TWENTY SURE EVEN THE
THERE MIGHT OFFEND. I THANK YOU
SIR RUBIO PLEASE. THANK YOU
SENATOR BATES JUST. IS THIS NOT
JUST FOR CLARIFICATION PURPOSES.
YOU CAN HEAR ME RIGHT YEAH.
THANK YOU CENTER BATES JUST FOR
CLARIFICATION PURPOSES I CAN
YOU JUST. X. AT LET ME KNOW IS
THIS PROHIBITS ANY CONSTRUCTION
ON THE S. R. TO FORTY ONE.
CENTER BATES I'M SORRY COULD
YOU REPEAT THAT WAS A LITTLE
MUTED SURE- CENTER BATES UP
THANK YOU- JUST FOR MY OWN
UNDERSTANDING THIS THIS IN ANY
WAY FOR HIM AT THE ADDITIONAL
CONSTRUCTION OF SR TWO FORTY
ONE. BETTER GET. HIM CITY
CONSTRUCTION TWO FORTY ONE
SOUTH OF THE ARTERIAL. ALSO HEY
AND THAT WAS. THE WHOLE ISSUE
DISCUSSED STOP AT THE ON MAY
TWELFTH- ON MARCH TWELFTH
MEETING THAT THEY WERE GOING TO
ABANDON THAT ROUTE YOU CAN MOVE
OVER TO THE LAST FOR YOUR OWN
S. EXTENSION WHICH- STUDY WILL.
HAVE ALL PERMITTED NUMBER
TWENTY TWO. THAT DECISION ON
MARCH TWELFTH IS THAT IT
MEETING- THE TRANSPORTATION
CORD OR BOARD AFTER. MUCH
DISCUSSION- ACTUALLY MADE IT
SOUND LIKE IN THEIR TESTIMONY
THAT THEY WERE NOT AN ACTIVE
BAND ANY ON THE TWO FORTY ONE
AND ALSO THAT THEY MAY NEED TO
KEEP THE OPTION. YEAH IS
SIGNIFICANT TRUSTED OF WHETHER
THE MEANS THE- WAS GOING TO BE
FINALIZED I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO MOVE THE BILL
FORWARD. SO WE CAN CONTINUE THE
ACTIONS ARE. WHAT WILL BE THE
ARCHIVES. ARE RELIEF PROJECT
THAT WILL IN SOUTH ORANGE
COUNTY. ARE I AM COMPLETELY OLD
ENSURE CONTINUING THE
DISCUSSION BUT I VERY IMPORTANT
TO CODIFY THE DECISION. THAT
WAS NAY BY. ALSO THAT THE
RESIDENTS MANY COME BACK TO THE
TEAM TO NEW. WHAT IS THE
SOLUTION FOR TRAFFIC CONGESTION
RELIEF IN THEIR AREA RIGHT NOW
WE HAVE YOU KNOW MULTIPLE
PROBLEMS AND JOHN. I THINK
TRUST THIS BE AND PROBABLY THE
BIGGEST ONE. I HEARD SHASTA TO
OF BOTH. ON I IN TODAY'S THE
BILL SO THAT I CAN. MY WORK
WITH BOTH SIDES OF ISSUE AND I
WILL SHARE WITH YOU HAD LATE
DISCUSSION WITH THE CHAIRMAN OF
OUR TRANSPORTATION TO FORTY
ONE. BOB AND I REMOVED THE
CONSERVE EASEMENT WHICH WAS THE-
SB SEVENTY THREE BECAUSE THAT
WAS A SIGNIFICANT FOR TRANSFER.
PLANNING IT OUR TO STAY THERE
WAS A THAT IT WOULD HAVE.
IMPACT ON MONEY TRANSFER. THERE
FOR MY- OPEN WILLING TO DO THAT
BOB IF YOU IN WHO ARE I KNOW SO
THINGS OF THAT KIND OF CAR BUT
I THINK IT'S ESSENTIAL AND
LOCAL NOT. ALL CONDEMNED TABLE
TO READ JUST. THAT'S ROLE IN
PROMOTING THEIR FINANCING A ON
CONVOCATION OF WHAT THEY DID
DECIDE IN A PUBLIC MEETING AND
I FORTUNATELY STARTED I DO IT
ANOTHER PUBLIC MEETING ON THE
CARPET JUST. SO THERE'S VERY
VERY. I THINK YOU ôNG THAT
SUBSTANTIAL IN HERE TRANCE
PROJECTS. ANYWHERE IN OUR STATE
THAT WE DO HAVE PEOPLE ON BOARD.
AND I WILL SHARE WITH YOU SOUTH
ORANGE COUNTY POOLS A SALES TAX.
HE A ARE PARTNERING WITH THE
STATE AND TRANSPORTATION
REJECTION MANISHA RELIEF AND
BECAUSE OF THE MANNER IN
PROCESS THAT WENT OVER TO
DESIGN ALL OF THE LINE THAT'S-
ORANGE COUNTY IT ALMOST 80%
SOME CELLS OR TRANSPORTATION
AND I THINK THAT SIGNIFICANT I
WAS PART OF THAT AND I WANT TO
KEEP THAT KIND OF ATTITUDE
GOING FORWARD ESPECIALLY WHEN
WE'RE DESIGNING TOLL ROADS
WHICH SOMETIMES DON'T RECEIVE
THE HIGHEST RATING FROM THE
PUBLIC. IS BY THE WAY I'VE BEEN
AND WITH THIS FOR SOME. I WAS
THE TRANSPORTATION CORPORATION
BOARDS AND I SERVED ON ORANGE
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
BOARDS AND PLEASE ACCEPT MY
WORD ON. THIS BILL IS THE BEST
VEHICLE TO MOVE FORWARD AND GET
A SOLUTION. FOR OUR SOUTH
COUNTY ON CONGESTION EACH. THE
OTHER QUESTIONS FROM OTHER
SENATORS THANK YOU SENATOR
BETTER RUBIO AND- THANK YOU
THANK YOU- OTHER QUESTIONS OF
OTHER SENATORS. WE HAVE NONE
THAT I CAN SEE THE CORRECT AND
WE WILL ASK CENTER BASE TO
CLOSE HER BATES. HELLO THANK
YOU AGAIN ALL IN IRAN ON
STRONGLY ASK FOR YOUR IDOLS.%
HELP ME MOVE A SOLUTION FORWARD.
THANK YOU. THE BILL IS MAN MADE
A MOST HAS BEEN MADE BY SENATOR
OR ROTH I BELIEVE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS THROUGH THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
THIS IS SB THIRTEEN SEVENTY
THREE BY SENATOR BATES THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BILL HI BILL HI
ALAN HI ELLEN AYE DOLLY HI THE
ONLY AYE DONE. THE BILL I BILL
JOHNNY I GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I
GROWTH I DROVE BY WHERE. WHERE
I MELENDEZ. WHEN DESIGN MORALE
HIGH MORALE HIGH ROTH HI ROTH
HI RUBIO. RUBIO I LIKE
HEALTHCARE. TWELVE TO ZERO GEN
THE VOTE ON THE BILL IS TWELVE
TO ZERO- THE BILL PASSES. WE
WANT TO OPEN THE ROLE OF FOR.
AT THIS TIME FOR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR- CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR WHICH
CONSISTS OF FILE ITEMS. ONE TWO
THREE FOUR FIVE SIX EIGHT NINE
AND TEN. BOTH GROW BY MCGUIRE
MCGUIRE AYE THIRTEEN ZERO
MISSION THE ROTOR APPROVED ON A
THIRTEEN A VOTE. THEN THANK YOU
TO ALL THE INDIVIDUALS
PARTICIPATE IN THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY. IF YOU WERE
NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS AND WRITING TO
THEIR TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE
OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD. THANK
YOU AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION. I THANK YOU
EVERYBODY FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION AND WE HAVE
CONCLUDED GENDO. THE SENATE
TRANSFER COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION IS NOW ADJOURNED.